the last thing that I do this is an
exercise I thought I this was unique to
me it's not so I used to do this years
ago and I still do it to this day and it
turns out there's a name to it it's Minh
negative thought exercise I call it
looking at the downside and so what I
like to do in order to control my
emotions because the thing we're
controlling your emotions is you have to
control the up and the down because when
you start a company or when you start
anything typically you have a fair bit
of highs and the highs are probably as
good feeling as you as you think or
maybe even a little bit less than you
think
but the downs are typically way worse
than you can imagine it's really hard to
control the Downs because when you start
anything
controlling the down is the hard part
and most people are shocked at how low
you can feel when you're starting
something even when things appear to be
going well and so what I like to do is I
like to think in my mind I'll close my
eyes I do this a lot of times in the
morning I'll do it at night as well as I
close my eyes and I think what's the
worst possible outcome right now and so
it could be I get sick my family gets
sick I'm gonna die and I visualize what
what that feels like and if you do it
for a long enough with your eyes closed
after about five or ten minutes you can
really feel what that feels like
and then I do two things I say to myself
all right that is the worst that can
happen I just experienced it anything
else that happens today it is only
upside and it really makes you have a
lot of gratitude and appreciate that
that hasn't actually happened and the
second thing that
to do with this exercises and this
relates particularly just starting a
company or getting a job or moving
somewhere else that's new and just
starting your life is I try to protect
the downside so for example if you are
gonna start a company you can ask
yourself well in order to start this
business I need a little bit of cash and
so you have to be very specific you have
to say how much cash do I need well
right now I'm spending $3,000 a month
how much how many months saved do I need
in order to feel good about this and so
let's say we come up with the number six
that means I need six times $3,000 I
need $18,000 in savings I'm gonna go out
and get that $18,000 okay I've got that
$18,000 what else is the worst-case
scenario here what's the downside here
well I could spend all my money and my
business goes under now do I want to be
homeless no I'm not willing to accept
being homeless okay so what's the net so
I have to protect myself from being
homeless how would I protect myself from
being homeless well I would probably get
a job driving uber because I have a car
do I want to am I willing to accept that
no I'm not willing to accept that or
maybe you are and then that's the
worst-case scenario but this one staged
up could be maybe well I'll just get a
white-collar job at a huge corporation
and I'll just be a cog in their big
wheel and their machine and it won't be
fulfilling it won't be glamorous but
it'll be a really good nine-to-five with
benefits benefits so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go and make friends with
recruiters at those companies right now
even though this isn't even coming close
to half it's not happening yet and so at
least at this point if something ever
bad happens I know that I have a
connection at IBM or I have a connection
at Target headquarters or I have a
connection at Intuit or just the biggest
companies in the world and the
likelihood that I can get a job there is
relatively high am I willing to accept
that that is the worst-case scenario yes
I am willing to accept that and so what
I do is I
up the scale of like alright well
where's the lowest that I'm willing to
accept now I'm gonna lock that that that
in as best as I can so now anything that
happens above this I am happy and it is
only upside and so that's what I like to
do to control my emotions when it comes
to taking risk
[Music]
you